we'd have shoot around I'll go home come
over joint taking that eat go to the
game I feel like this is the most
dynamic plant on earth no be naive to
the fact that this is helping people how
beneficial would it be then to legalize
if the league super beneficial basically
everyone here in this table has smoked
before and I think everyone always
remembers the first time they smoked so
I'll start with Cuttino do you member
your first time smoking what was about
yeah I just told the guys right before
this the first time I smoked with my
business partner me it was May 7th of
last year it was actually Blue Dream I
used to money my dad used to grow weed
so I used to steal it like flush off the
plant yeah you know I mean stems and
sticks and his seasons overly wet yeah
for me man it was uh it was actually
when I was playing in Golden State we
were in Phoenix and we sitting in the
room and uh and they went so we sitting
there and everybody pissed off switch
cuz you know we won more games with one
you know the we believe here and all
that so they just start sparking up and
they just like how you gonna hit this
and I'm like man I try it and I've been
smoking ever since I was a freshman in
college tried it once and put me out and
I like the feeling sitting there I got
queasy I was like yo so I know what that
meant I know what it means now I was
loli
[Laughter]
like out of my mind but I just tried it
again take that back it's probably gonna
be my land here did you ever play hi
honey what's um about that I never play
after smoking but we're playing in
Indiana one day like I wasn't feeling
well I hamstring a hip or something so I
smoked and outlines well I wouldn't go
play rhythm we got to the arena I like
better feel good they had a great game
yeah what does he do I was like you know
I like like 24 times am i double doubles
and I was like oh this is like I felt
great anybody else ever smoked like me
no you did my whole life really through
high school to college to the pros I was
14 I just found a way I'm telling them
myself but I'll go [__] now I mean I
would what I would do is I would do [__]
you know I mean we'd have shooting
around I go home smoke a joint
taking that wake up take a shower shower
was important shower waking me back up
eat and go to the game what was the best
game you remember all my best games I
was medicated I was that's like I said
like he said I mean he felt like he
couldn't play that night you know the
meaning he smoked and he went had a gig
like so it just I just knew what as much
as I could it wasn't every single game
but in 15 years it was a lot you know a
lot of people who smoked but a lot of is
behind the scenes and stuff like that
particularly in the NBA
how many causes smokers you think the
hell sure I think 85% of the league well
I think like our om basi last yeah like
early mid 2000s there's a lot of people
you wouldn't think presidents like as
far as you want to say closet I mean it
goes deeper than what you think some of
these people that are cracking width on
us trainers yeah some of the people in
the back and with the suspending us or
smoking weed
mostly everybody's a closet smoker all
my billionaire mentors or whatever they
all consume they smoke like they smoke
like crazy so how beneficial would it be
then to legalize it for the league very
its I mean listen super beneficial if
you have access to something if you have
information about something you will
become disciplined
enough to understand when I should take
it or when I shouldn't but will you have
someone telling you you cannot do
something you're going to fight that
system I don't care who you are when we
first came in the NBA we used to get
that one preseason drug test you can
rock the whole year yep I think you had
to do with some baseball steroid stuff
so we started and they knew that
marijuana was the only problem we didn't
know steroid problems they had a
perception that all these black athletes
are here smoking weed so how do you pass
the testing we rarely got in trouble -
we didn't really truthfully get in
trouble I got in trouble when all the
propositions were coming up to legalize
it like people were just crazy trying to
push the stuff or did you think there
was actually you know I believed in it
because like I said I've been a longtime
smoker and just have known what it's
capable of and I think it was fear or I
mean it's feared because of the
stereotypes we have today is it's
pictured as you know a gateway drug or
you know you know a black thing so to
speak and at the end of the day like
with cannabis like you know we can't go
out and say that it heals anything right
now because of the FDA and stuff like
that but we have all these stories where
it does reading up on like I help kids
with epilepsy and different things like
that how help people deal with so many
different issues you know I'm saying
even people like that are terminally ill
with cancer and HIV give them a better
quality of life you know I feel like
this is the most dynamic plant you know
on earth because it does so many things
I'll play 15 years like and made it
through like a lot of major injuries and
still was able to play at a high level
you know and as through most of my
career you know I'm saying me
self-medicate I'm only after the
basketball player to come back from -
microfracture surgery
each day and play basketball my my best
medicine I walk around to this day like
I've had made Rican major reconstructive
surgeons on my on my left ankle had my
patella repaired like I walk around man
and no pain my life is on TV man I'm
going through my mom dies when I'm
playing and going to state and I play
the next day the day after my mom dies I
get divorced on that you know me my
I have a reality-tv lifestyle my ex-wife
is with my former teammate like there's
a lot of [__] there but break normal
people you know what I mean
but I'm sitting back some I'm gonna join
able to laugh in my life because like
it's gonna be a crazy story when I get
older man you know what I mean like all
the [__] I didn't been through and I
didn't kill myself from non prison you
smoke when you was driving on the way
[Laughter]
that's what I'm saying it kept me sane
I've been someone to just smoke because
I know how it made me feel now
regardless appeals against the rules for
the NBA I knew what it kept me from
doing on a mental standpoint and how it
made me feel after we played it back to
back you know I mean heading into the
playoffs getting ready for the playoffs
like I just knew that ant-man I'm gonna
hit that my basketball feel better my
toe is gonna feel better my fingers I
broke all my fingers my fingers are
gonna be alright I just know like
tomorrow is gonna be you know a cool day
did you ever think that she'd be on
police report smoking I talked about we
I think alpha this you know I think I
really took a big step with really his
movement as a whole but you got to think
he sat down with David Stern you know
the NBA commissioner and now we're
leecher esporte smoking a joint how far
do you think we are from the NBA
allowing players I think yeah I think
they will allow Ken CBD cannabinoids I
think within next three to five years I
think I think there's enough testing
there I think there's enough people
telling you know the right stories I
think the world anti-doping agency they
just allowed you know CDs and the
Olympics and everything's like that so I
think some of those barriers are
starting to you know be knocked down but
you know what's crazy it's not so much
that not to cut you off al but it's not
so much the NBA says you could smoke
weed now it said they don't test for it
you know I mean we're the only major
sport that gets four random tests for
this all these sports football gets one
in the preseason in there tested for
steroids baseball same thing when we get
tested for you know street drugs right
so it's just like you know like I say
it's a stereotype drugs
it's a black athlete stereotype drugs
right we were the only league that they
test four times random for we'd like why
you're not to test for alcohol you know
it says for these are Dino mean these
pills that that are destroying our
insides that our trainers are giving us
you know I mean you tested for we
because you know we like to do it for us
this is our fraternities our family for
this right here it does so many
different things for us to calm us down
like you said to and I mean most guys
that I that I could think of all my
teammates that smoke they were always
the ones that was always liked them in
the house the children children always
in the house they weren't out like like
I'll be right here I'll cures from your
two perspectives though cuz obviously
you guys have investments within the
marijuana organizations and companies in
terms of what you guys are building do
you guys concern about the label of like
drug dealer how hard was that kind of
like the Box hours you guys understand
this was a business like Alma I'm a
cereal you know entrepreneur and like I
just like to jump off the cliff as long
as I understand what I'm doing right
like it's not like we used to like drug
those around the way it's not like that
but you're building a foundation alright
for me that made me feel better because
now I found my niche
not so much medical marijuana but just
being a businessman and learning a lot
of things I always believe it when
somebody tells you something
research it as much as you can you never
know that that could be your you know
light at the end of the tunnel so that's
the only reason I went for it I don't
know for me I've never been like shy
about it you know what I mean like if
somebody actually when I'm working on
what I got going on I would always
mention it so for me I haven't you know
I haven't met much resistance how I got
in you know I was in I was in Denver you
know what I mean my grandmother come to
see me she she's 81 years of the old the
time and she had like set up all her
medication like in the kitchen thirty
different pills damn I take all that
every day and she's like I'll take it
for this bad glaucoma bubble up she said
God come on about glaucoma nother day so
I'm telling her my grandma you know you
should actually try it and just see what
happens so like I said from Jersey where
like you know growing up anybody that
smoked we had no
like no you had no chance in making them
in life you know people just viewed you
is like he's done it was right you know
what I'm saying
so you know so I'm seeing here like
grandma should try it she like bullet so
first I told her you should try I called
the cannabis and she's like what's that
and I was like she's like look why don't
you just try to we you know what I'm
saying I was like because they said into
help and I was like I was like the
medicine you taking is not working as
well give it a shot
after a while she was like my eyes hurt
so bad today I'll try anything so I'll
call my boy he went got her some Vietnam
came back he bought his volcano cousin
lot so I got none of this [__] I just
had it whenever I was with the home so
he came for the volcano the vaporizing
we took in the garage she started
hitting me right so it was plenty about
that she's smoking in she's like I was
16 so whatever so we figured I'll take
her downstairs I take my neck so when I
wake up for my net was great jump in the
shower I said let's go check on her real
quick you don't understand they show
[__] down they're bugging out at
night so I go downstairs and I knock on
the door now back instead of doing she's
looking down so I walked to stick my
head into my grandma all right and she
turned around and she start crying she's
crying tears and she's like I'm healed
she's like you know I haven't been able
to read the words of my Bible in over
three years
and like she crying she made me start
crying and like after that it just
completely changed you know my
perception really at this point went
from just being a social thing that just
made me feel good to where I seem like
wow all that [__] I've been reading in
the paper it's actually true what is the
perception you want like rbr audience to
understand from this conversation about
athletes and particularly the NBA in
marijuana you can still be a successful
person and successful athlete it doesn't
make you a bad person if you
I'm consuming cannabis it doesn't make
you a bad person if you're still
functioning and taking care
responsibilities and doing all that you
can still be successful at what you're
doing so you can't fight the science of
it you know so do your homework
and don't be naive to the fact that it's
this helping people we're actually
trying to help you know I'm saying and
we're trying to to heal the world
essentially it's not about just the
monetary gains that we can get from this
you know I'm saying I really want to be
able to change people lives
I was thinking legacy now you know what
I'm saying I met with some of the people
from the MVP a during all-star week you
know in February and you know I was
telling all of them I said that first
chapter I wrote there's enough to
compare to this second one about
you